[Musique]
pour
aujourd'hui St jvv est le saint patron de
Paris sa statue de landowski se dresse sur
le pont de
[Musique]
LEL dans la seconde moitié du XIIe
siècle L'autorité morale de Louis 7 La
passion de Maurice doi pour la construction et
la découverte de  un nouveau mode de construction
avec des nervures et des contreforts
supportant une voûte a conduit à la
création de notredam
[Musique]
Cathédrale [
Musique]
aujourd'hui libérée des
édifices médiévaux qui l'entouraient la
conception impeccable de son côté ouest se
révèle cette façade présente en parfaite
unité le  Harmonie stricte d'un triple
rythme [Musique] triple
portail [Musique]
pour la galerie des
Rois [Musique] et la galerie supérieure ouverte,
les tours sur lesquelles sont perchés des
animaux fantastiques recréés par Vi luk
diminuent l'impression de massivité
en attirant le regard  depuis la construction carrée inférieure
Vers le
Ciel, après quelques instants de pause pour
s'habituer au mélange de
lumière et d'obscurité de l'intérieur, le visiteur peut
apprécier les doubles travées de la Nef, les
piliers cylindriques, les grandes
arcades, les galeries archaïques, la
voûte sextuple et la  chœur semi-circulaire
rayonnant de la lumière symbolique de
ses vitraux
dans North Bay la rosace la mieux conservée
date d'environ 1270 ses
tons bleus illustrent des sujets bibliques de
l'Ancien
[Musique]
Testament également sur l'île à l'
ombre du  Palais du
roi législateur qui le fit construire entre 1246 et
1248 se dresse la
Chapelle S dans ce reliquaire translucide
conçu pour contenir les reliques les plus vénérables
de la passion du Christ les
vitraux rayonnent
de toutes parts leur splendeur éblouissante
son élégante construction  est le
point culminant de l'architecture gothique à
Paris
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique] des
anciens habitants de la
dynastie Capan. Le Coner existe encore avec ses
quatre tours, trois rondes avec des
toits pointus et une tour carrée sur
laquelle en 1370  fut placée la
première horloge publique à
[Musique]
Paris en 1655 elle sonna l'
heure de gloire de la monarchie absolue lorsque Louis
XIV botté et éperonné avec un fouet à la
main dicta ses ordres au
Parlement mais elle sonna également en
1793 la fin de l'ancienne  régime le r de
la guillotine pour Mar
[Musique]
antoinet avant puis encore une fois au
Moyen Âge mais cette fois sur la rive
droite du fleuve le pouvoir
des Bourgeois commença à prendre
forme eten Marcel prouva des
marchands établis  le siège de la
commune à la maison des piliers
au pl de
grave François Ier fit construire un édifice
dans le style Renaissance de
son
époque détruit en grande partie lors de l'
insurrection communale de 1871 il fut reconstruit au
même
endroit son extérieur est  à peine modifié
mais les grandes salles de réception de l'
Hôtel de Ville actuel ont été conçues dans le style du
19ème siècle qui est très différent
de la décoration originale de la Renaissance
[Musique]
à proximité se trouve le
centre d'art et de culture Jor PPU ouvert en
1977  puis plus à l'est on arrive au
Mah qui comme son nom l'indique était des
Marais les ordres religieux furent les
premiers à s'y installer et commencèrent à
le rendre habitable puis de grands Nobles
vinrent y construire leurs demeures de campagne nommées
[Musique]
CTI l'Hôtel Des sance est un lieu rare
exemple d'architecture privée de la fin du XVe siècle
la façade est d'un grand
intérêt artistique avec des
tourelles en saillie des fenêtres d'mer et un
porche [Musique]
depuis sa restauration le CER de pré
témoigne du génie des bâtisseurs [Musique] du XVIIe siècle
Henri IV fut l'instigateur de
cette  transformation il créa l'
ancienne Place Royale aujourd'hui appelée pl
de
vge le premier bâtiment fut le Grand
Pavillon Sud dit Pavillon du Roi
qui fut achevé en 1608
l'Ensemble architectural est un
quadrilatère de 36 pavillons à
arcades alliant Pierre Blanche et
brique ocre rouge  façades avec l'ardoise de
ses hauts
toits en croupe Henri IV fut assassiné le
14 mai 1610 et ne vit donc pas l'
achèvement de la place royale dont l'
inauguration eut lieu en avril
1612. La place devint dès lors la
résidence à la mode de nombreux
célèbres  hommes et
femmes le quartier de mar possède plusieurs belles
propriétés comme l'hôtel Su l'
hôtel Del l'hôtel le subis l'hôtel
et le Shalon l
entre [
Musique]
d'autres
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui des rues pittoresques
existent encore comme le rud preo Charles
Quint  Rue la rue des lions
où vivait bodair rarang et bien d'
autres
[Musique]
la première pierre de la célèbre
forteresse du basti a été posée en 1370
elle a été conçue comme bastion militaire
et n'est devenue une prison d'état qu'à l'
époque de
rishu elle a été  démoli après le 14
juillet 1789 et pendant un certain temps le site
fut un lieu de prédilection pour les
promenades [musicales], mais en 18 40 il fut transformé en
place publique et une colonne fut érigée
surmontée d'une figure de l'esprit de la
Liberté  Prendre son envol alors qu'il brise ses
chaînes et répand la lumière de la
[Musique]
liberté
[Musique] [
Musique] Le
roi Henri IV en essayant son cheval
domine le POR n qui malgré son
nom est le plus vieux pont de
[Musique]
Paris
depuis 400 ans ceux  en s'y promenant, on a
pu admirer un
Panorama Monumental se reflétant dans les eaux du
fleuve sur les rives duquel se dressent les nobles
édifices érigés par une monarchie triomphale
[Musique]
le long de la rive droite s'étend le Lou
prolongé par le Tes formant Le Grand
Conception planifiée par des générations d'artistes
entre les anneaux de François Ier et
Napoléon
II
[Musique] un
travail considérable entrepris par le
Service des Bâtiments historiques du
Palais LOF a restauré l'
aspect original de l'architecture mais l'
ajout d'aménagements modernes et de nouvelles
techniques a été nécessaire pour  l'
accueil des visiteurs et la mise en valeur de
notre patrimoine culturel
la pyramide conçue par l'
architecte sino-américain P érigée au
centre du K Napoléon et bordée par
les trois façades des Pavillons rishu sui et
den a été inaugurée en avril
[Musique]
d'abord Forteresse puis habitation le
Lou cumule désormais ces deux fonctions
protégeant et abritant ses
hôtes cosmopolites parmi lesquels la Vénus
de l'île de Milo et la monaa
peinte par Léonard de
Vinci celle qui offre aux parisiens sa
beauté issue de l'Antiquité  le symbole
d'une civilisation méditerranéenne
dont notre culture est
imprégnée l'autre dans sa charpente blindée leur
transmet un salut souriant de
la renaissance italienne
[Musique] [
Musique]
l'ancienne gare et l'hôtel
ont été sauvés de la démolition en 1978  lorsqu'ils
furent classés monuments historiques
après une rénovation imaginative, ils sont
devenus le Musée O ouvert au
public fin
1986.
[Musique]
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir
des œuvres d'art très diverses telles que des
peintures, des sculptures et des revêtements de pastels.  la
période de 1848 à
[Musique]
1914 jusqu'à lre rir SI San vog et bien d'
autres sont représentés dans les
salles spacieuses du
musée [Musique] [
Musique]
le design de l'hôtel valed est un splendide
chef-d'œuvre conçu par les libéraux bruan
et ardan marar pour le  grand roi qui
l'avait conçu dans un double but l'un
charitable comme maison de repos pour les
soldats vétérans l'autre purement égocentrique comme
personnifié dans l'Église Royale
dominée par le contour subtil de son
[Musique]
Dôme
le grand empereur y repose dans son rouge
tombeau en granit près du peuple de France
qu'il aimait tant par ce témoignage il
éclipse la gloire du Roi Soleil Louis
le
[Musique]
14e [
Musique]
Louis 15e Louis 14e arrière
-petit-fils a également contribué à l'
embellissement de Paris par la création  de
la vaste Place qui portait à l'origine
son nom puis devint plus tard la place de
la Révolution et enfin de la
Concorde
elle fut conçue par Gabriel pour servir de
cadre Monumental à la
statue équestre du Roi Bien-Aimé comme Louis
XV était
connu son petit-fils Louis  le 16e y fut
décapité le 21 janvier
1793. Au centre de la place se dresse
le plus ancien monument de Paris l'
obélisque de Lua gravé il y a 33 siècles de
hiéroglyphes glorifiant le pharaon Ramsey
II.
Vers le nord on découvre la perspective
de la rue Royale menant à la
[Musique  ]
Medan lui faisant face sur la rive droite se trouve
le siège P bourbon de l'Assemblée nationale
[Musique] [
Musique]
car
l'avenue au nom mythologique
Sha Eliz ou Elian Fields est une section de
l'axe Est-Ouest selon un
auteur de la période au XVIIIe siècle
c'était soit Torride soit Gelé un champ
de boue ou de poussière qui disloque
les voitures attache leurs chevaux et
anéantit tout piéton malchanceux qui
prend le risque de venir dans ce
[Musique]
lieu
mais Paris  lentement amélioré sa
prominade favorite elle se concluait par l'Arc
de Triomphe construit par Shaly à partir de 1806
à la gloire du nouveau César
Napoléon
la
[Musique]
sur un de ses pairs l'
oratoire flamboyant de la victoire de Rude aux bras
tendus dans un air héroïque  le geste
symbolise notre hymne national
[musique]
sous l'arche une population enar rend
hommage au sacrifice de ses plus
humbles soldats la flamme éternelle brûle
sur le parterre de fleurs de la dalle sacrée
sous laquelle se trouve la tombe du
soldat inconnu de la première guerre mondiale
[Musique]
à l'ouest sur la rive opposée du
S fermement ancrée dans la verdure du
Sha Mar par un ingénieur au milieu de
structures métalliques, la Tour Eiffel a finalement
réussi à être acceptée comme un
monument familier entre l'Académie militaire de Gabriel
et le pet shayu datant de
l'exposition
[Musique] de 1937,
l'audace de sa conception
peut s'exprimer en tonnes 7 000
en mètres 320 jusqu'au sommet de l'
antenne de télévision 274 jusqu'à la
plate-forme la plus haute d'où l'on peut voir une
vue plongeante sur la capitale  et ses
environs la tour est dans tous les
sens du terme le sommet du tourisme
et de l'industrie du souvenir avec ses
15 000 poutres métalliques boulonnées ensemble par
2 millions et demi de rivets elle
symbolise depuis son ouverture en 1889 Paris plus
que tout autre
monument
[  Musique]
[Musique]
un autre point culminant de la Rive Gauche le
bien plus modeste avec ses 60 5 m le mang
s genv sert de base aux
fondations du
pon commencé par soufo à la manière des
grandes églises doom achevées  au
début de la Révolution il
devient ensuite un vaste morsum destiné à recevoir
les cendres d'hommes célèbres Vol B Victor
Hugo Zola et Jean Mulan entre autres
plus bas au Luxembourg avec ses étangs ses
terrasses ses parterres de fleurs à la française
et ses jardins paysagers à l'anglaise
une oasis de fraîcheur et de verdure
Tranquillité sur les
résidents et les étudiants des résidences voisines et un terrain de jeu
pour les enfants qui viennent profiter du
spectacle de marionnettes, c'est aussi le cadre du nouveau
Palais que Mari deichi, la veuve d'
Henri IV, fit construire aujourd'hui par Salamon de Bross.
est le siège du
Sénat
[Musique]
comme il est agréable de flâner dans les
rues entre le boulevar au S
autour du vénérable peuple roman
de s De
[Musique]
PR le groupe précédent et le
Duo existentialiste de  Le sud et le bou hantent encore
ce quartier de librairies antiquaires
Discothèques souterraines Cafés en terrasse
et dizaines appelés Flor lip et [
Musique]
Leo
[Musique]
au fond de l'avenue DEA créée
sous le Second Empire par le baron Osman
se dresse l'Opéra P gar  Maison
contemporaine de Vagner et
dont
la façade de style Napoléon III ainsi
nommée par l'architecte lui-même
se compose d'une terrasse monumentale à arcades
sous un lodia et d'un immense dôme
couronnant l'édifice qui est orné
d'un ensemble de statues et de groupes
notamment celui de  la danse par
kpo
[Musique]
la botte ou hilock de morat s'élève au-dessus
des toits pour considérer le nom morat
comme dérivé du Mont des Martys est
un fantasme écologique bien que
selon la légende c'est là que saint Denis fut
décapité la basilique et  Immaculée
Construction de style byzantin romain
dédiée au Sacré-Cœur de Jésus
perpétue la tradition chrétienne depuis
le sommet de la colline
[Musique]
pour
oh
[Musique]
tôt le matin à une courte distance
de la pl D les lucarnes roses
installent leurs chevalets  prêtes pour les
touristes
[Musique]
les rues du village sont toujours aussi
escarpées et étroites que les anciennes ruelles
qui serpentaient à travers les
vignes et une certaine culture du raisin
a encore lieu maintenant à mormal assez
près du mul de galet  peint par rir
en face du giron ail où la
fraternité bohème se joignait à Bron pour chanter
des ballades réalistes poètes et peintres
Picasso Brock matis van dongan
appolinaire Max Jacob rencontré à bord du B
lavoir Phare du cubisme et c
[Musique]
r [
Musique]
[Musique]
laisser
laisser [
Musique]
il
[Musique
] e [Musique]
e [
Musique]
à
[Musique]
spe [
Musique]
tout [
[Musique]